incidents à l'assemblée nationale et au
sénat le premier ministre met
brutalement en cause la position du rpr
sur le référendum
le rpr quittent les lieux pas de pilule
abortive sur le marché on s'est loupé
lave recul face aux attaques des groupes
de pression catholiques et des
laboratoires concurrents
la réaction de michel andré secrétaire
d'état aux droits de la femme prison
bientôt modification du système de la
détention provisoire pour en limiter la
durée et le champ d'application de
nouveaux raids israéliens au sud liban
aujourd'hui il s'accrocha me refuse
l'idée d'une conférence internationale
de paix sensation à moscou selon le
chancelier allemand helmut kohl
les soviétiques libérerait tous leurs
prisonniers politiques
ici la fin de l'année madame monsieur
bonsoir que ceux qui s'ennuient de la
politique quand elle est trop
consensuelle sans orient ni éclats de
voix se rassurent rien ne va plus entre
le gouvernement et le rpr pour la
première fois depuis le début de cette
législature
à l'assemblée comme au sénat les
questions d'actualité ont été pimentés
d'incidents cet après midi les sénateurs
rpr ont refusé de siéger pour écouter le
message du président de la république
invitant à voter le référendum
calédonien les députés rpr de leur côté
ont carrément quitté l'hémicycle objets
dorgogne des propos très durs à leur
encontre dans la bouche du premier
ministre pascal guimier orages et
passion au palais-bourbon pleins feux
sur la nouvelle calédonie et la
température prend brutalement des
allures tropicales
il est 15 heures et 32 minutes michel
rocard s'en prend tout rpr qui a choisi
de s'abstenir au référendum
un ton digne d'un meeting pour une vraie
tempête dans l'hémicycle la position du
affaires se ramène en fait un slogan
unique
courage fuyons
jusqu ici jusqu'à ce jour jusqu'à cette
décision on avait mesdames et messieurs
les députés jamais songé à rapprocher
gaullisme et désertion gaullisme et
lâcheté réactions outragées des
gaullistes une sortie de groupe des plus
voyante avant un florilège d'indignation
dans les couloirs tout à fait la malle
au goût de panique d'un homme qui
cherche absolument à provoquer avec ses
vocations est excellent on sait pas si
une telle arme c'est le premier ministre
dans les fermes à qualifiables je crois
que là on avait quelque chose qui n'est
pas à la hauteur d'un premier ministre
mais c'est pierre de bénouville
compagnons de la libération qui
exprimera officiellement la colère du
rpr trop c'est trop
préposé aux risques parlementaire
nageurs jean poperen tentera alors de
jouer les soldats du feu de cet incident
l'opposition ce soir ressort comme
ressouder udf et centristes s'associant
aux gaullistes effets pervers peut-être
d'un propos plutôt destiné à remobiliser
l'électorat de gauche depuis le meeting
de belfort hier soir on savait en tout
cas que michel rocard avait choisi à la
fois de monter lui-même au créneau et
aussi de durcir le ton vis-à-vis du rpr
pour des raisons de conviction sans
doute mais aussi de tactiques nucléaires
où il nous sommes en campagne électorale
voilà ce que subitement michel rocard
vient de rappeler à ce qui peut être
l'avait un peu oublié l'ouverture et les
propos rassembleurs n'empêche pas les
choix clair voilà le message du premier
ministre depuis plusieurs jours mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya un changement de ton
de la part de michel rocard depuis le
début de la campagne officielle un coup
d'accélérateur motivé sans doute par une
double analyse d'abord il ya le risque
d'abstention le fort risque d'abstention
tout le monde le sait matignon aussi
rien de tel donc à ce moment là pour
mobiliser au moins ses électeurs que
deux politisé l'enjeu en outre le
premier ministre a bien reçu la semaine
dernière le signal d'alarmé du parti
socialiste à l'occasion des conflits
sociaux
ce langage aujourd'hui plus musclé a
pour but sans aucun doute de rassurer
les militants socialistes
enfin face à ce référendum le rpr
et embarrassé parfois divisés jacques
chirac est silencieux michel rocard
exploite donc la faille et remue à sa
manière la fibre gaulliste sur un thème
sensible le thème du référendum mais ce
ton nouveau qui tranche sans aucun doute
avec celui adopté par le premier
ministre depuis cinq mois comporte
néanmoins un risque celui d'être décalé
par rapport à l'image actuelle de michel
rocard un décalage constaté en tout cas
le par les centristes dès cet après midi
mais sans majorité absolue aujourd'hui
michel rocard à l'heure des rendez vous
électoraux a choisi la combativité en
n'oubliant pas sans aucun doute son camp
et les dirigeants du rpr que nous avons
voulu inviter ce soir refuse de
s'exprimer pour ne pas tomber dans le
piège en quarts bien dit steen
notons aussi la prise de position des
évêques réunis à lourdes pour leur
conférence épiscopale le cardinal
decourtray qui préside cette conférence
a plaidé pour la participation sinon
pour le oui au référendum
refroidissement des relations sociales
aux communistes le parti communiste
refuse tout accord national pour
constituer des listes de gauche aux
prochaines municipales
la rencontre marcel debarge paul laurens
matin n'a duré qu'une demi-heure et
aucun autre rendez-vous n'a été pris
andré lajoinie le président du groupe
communiste à l'assemblée sera demain
matin l'invité de gérard morin aux 4
vérités
c'est une marche arrière spectaculaire
que roussel uclaf le groupe
pharmaceutique a annoncé aujourd'hui
c'est aussi un recul dans la
modernisation des méthodes pour
interrompre volontairement des
grossesses non désirées
il ya moi je vous l'avais annoncé le
ministère de la santé avait autorisé la
mise sur le marché d'une pilule abortive
à proprement surnommée pilule du
lendemain dont l'utilisation était
d'ailleurs limité au centre spécialisé
depuis des groupes de pression surtout
catholiques en france et à l'étranger
faisait campagne contre ce nouveau
produit
on sait du claf a préféré abandonner le
marché jean daniel flaysakier daniel
voici la désormais fameuse ru486 cette
pilule aujourd'hui objet de scandale est
appelée parfois à tort pilule du
lendemain
son principe c'est d'empêcher le
développement de l'embryon dans l'utérus
son efficacité supérieure à 95%
lorsqu'elle est associée à des
prostaglandines qui déclenche des
contractions de lutter
premièrement c'est un médicament à part
entière c'est dire qu'il a subi tous les
contrôles et les avis nécessaires y
compris celui du comité d'éthique en 87
avant d'être autorisés sur le marché il
ya seulement un mois
deuxièmement c'est un médicament qui
s'inscrit dans le cadre de la loi sur
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
c'est-à-dire qu'elles supposent des
garde-fous médicaux uniquement prescrit
dans les centres d'orthogénie est
administré en présence d'un médecin
après un délai de réflexion de huit
jours
inondé quotidiennement de lettres de
menaces de mort contre ces cadres oursel
va donc provisoirement suspendre la mise
à disposition du produit en france ce
qui on s'en doute divise encore un peu
plus adversaires et partisans de
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
nous disons clairement le ru486
représente une menace grave malgré les
fragile barrière qui ont été élevés
un nouveau seuil de la banalisation de
l'avortement vient d'être franchie le
problème de l'interdiction de cette
pilule est un problème qui est un
révélateur d'un état de notre société
aujourd'hui où l'église dans sa
hiérarchie cléricale entend faire la loi
alors que répétons le
avortement ou pilule aucune forme que
ses convictions religieuses
philosophiques ou politiques empêcherait
de pratiquer d'utiliser la paix lui les
contraintes de le faire de même le
groupe va suspendre ses démarches pour
lancer le produit aux états unis en
amérique du sud dans ces pays en effet
de puissants lobbys anti avortement
menace de boycotter roussel or la
filiale américaine de russel préparait
le lancement d'une série de produits
majeurs comme la roxy trop micinn un
antibiotique très important pour le
groupe ou aussi des produits destinés au
traitement du cancer de la prostate des
médicaments au chiffre d'affaires
potentiel énorme comparé à ceux du et
rue économiquement donc le retrait du
ru486 ne devrait pas pénaliser un groupe
qui a semble-t-il bien d'autres fers au
feu
la réaction maintenant du secrétaire
d'état chargée des droits de la femme
madame andrée bonsoir alors de retraite
ces pilules à bord
comment réagissent et écoutez je viens
de l'apprendre à l'instant je suis un
peu étonné de voir que une fois de plus
les phénomènes d'intolérance se
manifeste d'une façon qui est pas
différente de certaines autres mais
c'est extrêmement dommage pour les
femmes et pour la liberté qu'on a avec
son corps et avec la facilité ou la
difficulté d'avoir un enfant la
législation sur la contraception reste
bien sûr en vigueur mais c'est quand
même un recul
oui je considère cette à reculer je
pense que nous serons obligés d'en
parler à certains niveaux dans notre
pays parce que ça paraît très étonnant
puisque médicalement apparemment il n'y
avait pas de problème particulier je
trouve tout à fait dommage et je
comprends mal comment on arrive à des
extrêmes de cette nature et comment ces
pressions font de cette façon là madame
andrée vous avez été chargé par le
premier ministre de poursuivre les
dialogues avec les infirmières qui vont
à nouveau manifester demain lorsque vous
avez en tête des mesures concrètes
le premier ministre m'a confié une
mission qui est effectivement une
mission de dialogue d'écouté qu'il a
qualifié de longue durée et de terrain
c'est à dire qu'il m'a demandé d'aller
dans les hôpitaux et de travailler au
plus près sur le territoire de notre
pays pour voir quel est le phénomène
salaires le phénomène par salaires
seulement en plus ce n'est pas tout à
fait mon rôle mais comment le fait
d'être femme pose un problème
particulier et j'ai une mission de
longue haleine en fait donc je crois
qu'il faut la construire avec la
patience qu'elle mérite
alors ce matin au conseil des ministres
vous avez présenté trois projets pour
mieux insérer les femmes dans la vie
économique et aussi dans la vie civique
on va en parler dans un instant mais
d'abord votre réaction à cet arrêt de la
cour européenne de justice selon la cour
la france n'observe pas là juste égalité
hommes femmes dans le travail
paradoxe et considère que ce sont les
hommes qui sont défavorisés par
certaines mesures dont bénéficient en
france les femmes qui travaillent
véronique auger halte au féminisme en
france elles ont droit à une pause et
pas à eux
mêmes inégalités entre les dactylos
hommes et les femmes au troisième enfant
les femmes peuvent prendre leur retraite
plus tôt et pas les zones elles ont
droit à des congés pour soigner leur
progéniture et pas injuste et surtout
non conformes à la législation
européenne
il va falloir changer cela les
dispositions cache sexe pourrait suffire
du genre le père ou la mère de trois
enfants peut prendre sa retraite plus
tôt cette mise au point de se faire très
vite sinon les avantages risque de
disparaître pour tout le monde qu'on
peut craindre tout en espérant que ça
n'arrivera pas c'est que des chefs
d'entreprise qui ont des textes
conventionnels s'appuient sur la
décision de la cour de justice
européenne pour supprimer comme illégaux
ou comme reconnu illégaux des avantages
spécifiques aux femmes
malgré l'urgence un flottement est à
craindre en effet qui va changer ses
textes les partenaires sociaux par la
négociation collective ou bien le
gouvernement par la loi alors justement
va la vendre et ce qu'on va devoir
revenir sur ces dispositions spécifiques
qui favorisait les femmes au travail
en théorie elle les favoriser en
pratique que ça tombe particulièrement
mal parce que j'étais en train de
repartir avec un projet de réseau
d'entreprise qui pouvait donner quelques
chances complémentaire aux femmes
donc je crois que je vais attendre la
décision officielle et prendre contact
avec mon collègue du travail parce que
pour ma part je ne suis pas prête à
abandonner l'idée de du plus pour les
femmes du positif pour les femmes et
déjà ces annonces toutes les
modifications que l'harmonisation des
règles européenne va va imposer aussi en
france oui mais on peut peut-être penser
que les européens comme les français ont
peut-être du mal à admettre l'égalité
professionnelle des femmes il faudra
bien en parler aussi au niveau de
l'europe avec les autres membres des
gouvernements et
mes collègues quand il y en a alors
madame andrée je crois qu'il y a quatre
femmes ministres sur sur combien sur 48
dans ce gouvernement au caire est ce que
c'était saisissent démocratie j'en ai
oublié de 20 sur 46 est ce que c'était
c'est non ça n'est pas tout à fait mais
nous allons essayer de faire mieux
moi je sais d'engager les femmes à
rentrer dans la vie municipale assumer
des responsabilités et à faire une
progression politique d'une nature
solide durable et j'espère que aux
élections municipales et bien les maires
hommes femmes mais les hommes qui
conduiront des listes vont être
intéressés par cet aspect de la présence
des femmes et de leur qualité
et ça c'est un message aux dirigeants du
parti socialiste dont souffre cette
partie dont vous êtes non pas seulement
des du parti socialiste c'est un message
vers les maires des communes qui savent
bien que la réalité c'est que les femmes
sont actives dans les communes et
qu'elles sont capables d'assumer leur
leur rôle d'élu d'un des très bonnes
conditions c'est un message vers les
élus et aussi vers les partis parce
qu'ils sont responsables de la place des
femmes au niveau de la construction des
listes dans les grandes villes en
particulier madame andrée merci c'est
vrai qu'il reste beaucoup à faire au
conseil des ministres de ce matin autre
projet important était présenté par le
garde des sceaux il s'agit d'une réforme
de la détention provisoire qui aurait
pour effet entre autres de désengorger
les prisons
en ce moment vous le savez un détenu sur
deux attend de passer en jugement
dominique verdeilhan un détenu sur deux
n'a pas encore été jugé plus de 22 mille
prisonniers sont aujourd'hui en
détention provisoire point fort du
projet de loi du garde des sceaux pire
arpaillange réduire les délais légaux
d'un quart arrière sont deux mois au
lieu de quatre en matière
correctionnelle fin non au maximum pour
les affaires criminelles de six mois à
un mois selon le daily pour les mineurs
autre aspect de ce projet de loi
l'obligation pour le juge d'instruction
de motiver sa décision de mise en
détention
à défaut d'un dénoncé précis de ses
motivations la demande d'incarcération
sera annulée des mesures qui si elles
sont appliquées dès mars 89 pourrait
aussi à moyen terme
désengorger les établissements p
et en sierre victimes de la
surpopulation c'est delà des objectifs
un objectif de désencombrement des dix
anciens mais ça ne peut pas être le seul
car le désencombrement des
établissements ne peut pas se faire au
détriment de la sécurité publique
c'est surtout parce que c'est un
problème j'allais dire purement
humanitaire et déontologique de ne pas
avoir dans deux établissements
pénitentiaires des personnes présumées
innocentes pendant une période
excessivement landes volonté de ce
projet de loi renforcer le droit de
l'inculpé au regard de la détention
provisoire ainsi le prévenu qui
souhaitent faire appel après un refus de
mise en liberté par un juge pourra se
présenter devant la chambre d'accusation
enfin des mesures d'accompagnement
seront renforcées afin de favoriser une
meilleure réinsertion
une loi qui sera discuté très
prochainement à l'assemblée et qui
passait depuis plus d'un an le projet de
réforme de l'instruction perturbations
dans les transports en commun à paris
direction et syndicats de la ratp sont
parvenus à un accord mais le trafic
n'est pas encore tout à fait normale
notamment sur la ligne a du rer
la grève des transports en commun se
poursuit à mulhouse à saint-etienne et
surtout à nantes où elle dure maintenant
depuis huit jours grève surprise aussi
aujourd'hui massivement suivis à lyon
cette grève devrait être reconduite
demain à l'origine du conflit des
revendications de salaires et de
conditions de travail
le geste est spectaculaire et la non ce
ne l'est pas moins
à moscou où il poursuit sa visite
officielle helmut kohl le chancelier
ouest allemand a déclaré aujourd'hui que
ses interlocuteurs soviétique s'était
dit prêt à libérer d'ici la fin de
l'année tous les prisonniers politiques
dans le pays
il n'y a pas de confirmation du côté des
autorités soviétiques qui de toute façon
ne reconnaissent pas officiellement
l'existence de cet hôtel prisonniers
jean marc qui nous prisonniers
politiques ou prisonniers de droit
commun
toute l'ambiguïté de la décision
annoncée aujourd'hui par moscou et dans
le choix des mots officiellement ces
hommes filmés par antenne 2 mais sans
interview dans une prison à 250 km de
moscou ne peuvent être que des droits
communs officiellement il n'y a pas de
prisonniers politiques en urss
est ce que propose aujourd'hui mouscou
c'est de libérer tous ceux
le site que l'occident considère comme
des prisonniers politiques
quarante ou cinquante personnes avait
dit en octobre un responsable soviétique
en y ajoutant une douzaine de condamnée
pour activités anti soviétique article
70 et 100 90 1 du code pénal de russie
un chiffre qui avait paru bien modeste
aux organisations occidentales des
droits de l'homme qui peut en effet
affirmé que parmi des détenus comme ceci
aucun n'était là pour raisons politiques
ou pratiques religieuses illégales
récemment les autorités soviétiques se
sont déclarées prêtes à ouvrir leurs
hôpitaux psychiatriques aux médecins
occidentaux
et c'est vrai les personnes interpellées
dans la plupart des manifestations
récentes en urss ont été relâchés dans
les cartons jaunes alors les libérations
annoncées aujourd'hui à moscou
sonne-t-elle vraiment la fin du goulag
il faut d'abord attendre de connaître
les chiffres et si l'annoncé suivies
d'effets les négociations en cours entre
moscou et les pays occidentaux en serait
sûrement faciliter les relations germano
soviétique en tout cas sont au beau fixe
d'après monsieur cole cet accord de
coopération ont été signés une trentaine
de contrats conclus par les industriels
allemands qui étaient du voyage
israël continue de se venger de
l'attentât à la voiture piégée contre
son armée mercredi dernier au sud-liban
de nouveaux raids aériens aujourd'hui et
une offensive importante de la milice
pro israélienne de l'armée du liban sud
au brier de l'air
représailles à répétition pour l'armée
israélienne qui a attaqué aujourd'hui
plusieurs positions palestiniennes et
druzes au liban premier raid lancé ce
matin le camp palestinien demi aimiez à
quelques kilomètres de la ville
libanaise de saïda de série de pics et
effectué quatre missiles lâchés sur ce
secteur qui abrite des militants de l'ol
paie alors qu'en début d'après-midi la
chasse israélienne pilonnait cette fois
des localités druzes proche de beyrouth
la milice pro israélienne de la hells
lançait à son toit une vaste offensive
sur la région de farfan house
l'envergure et la soudaineté de
l'opération ont permis aux deux mille
hommes de l'armée du liban sud de
reconquérir après plusieurs heures de
combats acharnés trois positions
stratégiques que leur avaient ravi des
militants intégristes sunnites et les
miliciens chiites d'amal concomitante
sinon officiellement coordonner ces zapa
coup franc tout cas à une semaine des
élections israéliennes
la volonté affichée d'itzhak rabin le
ministre de la défense et de ses amis
travailliste de pratiquer sans rejeter
la négociation la fermeté pour préserver
la sécurité d'israël
oui la campagne électorale en israel bat
son plein à quelques jours du scrutin le
premier ministre et chef du likoud lui
récuse toute idée de conférence
internationale souhaitée entre autres
par la france et l'egypte il l'a dit à
charles enderlin dix maisons sur une
colline en plein désert
cette nouvelle implantation en
cisjordanie c'était ce matin
la réponse du premier ministre itzhak
shamir aux dernières grandes manoeuvres
diplomatiques au proche orient
une inauguration très médiatisé
symbolique
l'occasion pour le chef du likoud la
droite de rappeler ces grands principes
non un état palestinien non à une
conférence internationale des positions
dures mais avec peut-être des
arrière-pensées que monsieur shamir
laisse à peine deviner dans son bureau
loin de la campagne électorale et nous
ne négocierons jamais avec le lp parce
que le npa n'est pas née vais pas adapté
à mes clients même s'il dit vous
proposez l'autonomie administrative aux
palestiniens
c'est à dire des élections en
cisjordanie et à gaza rien su c'est la
première pas des nôtres nommé ce sont
des élections démocratiques dans les
solutions
tu devrais tout seul car à la population
avec elle peut y avoir aussi des
candidats pro ump il ya des risques
qu'on prend pour la paix aussi mais ce
soir à nouveau devant son public il 5
shamir promet que voter likoud c'est
prendre un minimum de risques ne pas
brader les territoires comme dit il le
propose la gauche les travaillistes
l'autre campagne électorale américaine
s'accélère et le candidat démocrate
continue de perdre du terrain
le dernier sondage lui donne 13 points
de retard sur george bush le président
reagan est monté au créneau aujourd'hui
pour défendre son vice-président contre
ce qu'ils appellent les agressions des
libéraux le président reagan qui n'a
jamais été aussi haut dans les sondages
de popularité
les américains lui savent gré de la
prospérité économique de la baisse du
chômage même si personne ne nie
l'extension de la pauvreté aux états
unis elle touche 30 millions
d'américains sur 280 ce sont les exclus
de la croissance comme nous le montre
paul nahon et francis friedland
les hommes laissent les sans abri
plusieurs millions qui ont désormais
toutes les grandes cités américaines
ils sont l'un des principaux enjeux de
la campagne électorale bataille autour
des chiffres officiels de la misère avec
une certitude en quatre ans les riches
sont devenus plus riches et les pauvres
plus pauvres
pour ces derniers un scénario désormais
classique perte de l'emploi père du
logement de robes et solitude voici
leurs principales occupations laver les
pare-brises ils sont partout à tous les
croisements en plein coeur de la ville
salaire moyen de l'un de ces jeunes 300
francs par jour mais la population
refuse de plus en plus de données excédé
par cette armée de pauvres qui augmente
chaque jour un peu plus
si je faisais un vrai travail je
toucherai moins que le salaire minimum
c'est à dire 20 francs de l'heure c'est
impossible de vivre avec cela
après avoir payer mes factures
j'aurais plus un rond
nous avons rencontré d'avis et anna
langue de la 55e rue et de la 11e avenue
ils se sont connus sur un pare-brise
ils vivent et travaillent ensemble
depuis deux ans d'avis et anas sont la
mauvaise conscience de cette amérique
comme en posséder produire autant de
richesses avec autant de familles qui
vivent au dessous du seuil de la
pauvreté
le travail quotidien de ce jeune couple
procure juste assez pour 3 sandwich par
jour du lait et quelquefois un peu de
drogue très bon marché dans les rues de
new york
retour le soir dans le bronx l'un des
quartiers les plus pauvres et dévasté de
la ville deux à trois familles vivent
dans ces appartements prêtés par
l'assistance publique
vous savez lavez les pare brise c'est un
travail comme un autre
j'y passe des heures chaque jour ça ne
paye mes repas et l'avenir
pour vous il n'ya pas d'avenir ici on
survit à peine je dois manger tous les
jours pour rester en vie
vous y arrivez oui regardez d'avis et
anna vont repartir travailler au coin de
la 55e rue et de la 11e avenue et davy
se souvient qu'un soir de noël
un automobiliste lui a donné un billet
de 50 dollars 300 francs il était enfin
riche élections aujourd'hui en afrique
du sud des élections municipales où pour
la première fois tous les gros princiaux
ont été appelés à voter
séparément bien sûr emmanuel vanier des
élections municipales sous haute
surveillance
armée et police en alerte auprès des
bureaux de vote plusieurs incidents des
coups de feu et quatre bombes à
johannesburg mais pas de blessé pour la
première fois noir métis et blanc voté
le même jour
pour des scrutins totalement séparées
pour les conseils municipaux blanc recul
du parti du président pieter botha au
profit de l'extrême droite est le
principal enseignement de ces élections
c'est la très faible participation des
noirs
monseigneur desmond toutou avait lancé
un appel au boycott qui est parti anti
apartheid n'étaient même pas autorisés à
présenter des candidats pour les leaders
noirs les résultats de ces élections
n'auront aucune signification
lancement vendredi matin du satellite de
télévision directe tdf à par une fusée
ariane
dès janvier prochain images de haute
qualité et son stéréo pour cinq chaînes
non encore choisis seront donc à la
disposition du public à condition de
s'équiper d'une antenne parabolique et
d'un décodeur ou environ 6000 francs à
condition aussi que le satellite
fonctionne correctement son frère jumeau
allemand tv sat 1 lancé il ya un an
était victime d'une panne
il est aujourd'hui considérée comme
perdue
la navette spatiale soviétique sur son
pâtir lancement samedi matin son nom
pour anne la tempête de neige pour son
premier vol ba d'équipage mais un pilote
automatique pour le retour sur terre
burhan ressemble étrangement à discovery
l'américaine même poids même silhouette
même hublot les lois de l'aérodynamique
doivent être les mêmes pour tous affirmé
récemment un diplomate soviétique avant
d'ajouter mais peut être avons nous
aussi utiliser une photocopieuse le
tennis bercy mats wilander à la grippe
le numéro un mondial vient de déclarer
forfait il devait jouer ce soir guy
forget s'est qualifié pour les quarts de
finale en battant en deux sets
l'autrichien mystère quand winogradsky
il vient de jouer contre l'argentin
qualité et il a perdu 6 4 6 1
football de rencontre aujourd'hui en
coupe d'europe bordeaux a battu les
hongrois du ch baisse de 2 à 1 but à 0
un petit exploit
francis maroteaux stade de bazas à
budapest trois minutes de jeu faute du
bordelais rohr sur le hongrois saab ou
en blanc coup franc du milieu de terrain
international cosma sur la transversale
plus je pèse plus du bois mais c'est
bordeaux qui a de la chance
vingt minutes plus tard faute de vulliod
milk cette fois sur katona et nouveau
coup franc
cosma toujours lui qui veut jouer en
france il a déclaré se joue du mur
français poteau gauche best re touche du
bois
et puis bordeaux va toucher le gros lot
dans les arrêts de jeu de la première mi
temps
enzo scifo le milieu de terrain loin
devant pour yannick stopyra stopyra qui
filent stopyra qui fera et stopyra qui
marque 1 0 pour les girondins face au
club du ministère de l'intérieur
hongrois
score final est bonne affaire pour le
football français en voyage qui retrouve
enfin une certaine ambition et en sport
mais monaco joue contre bruges à bruges
score nul jusqu'ici 0 à 0 le louvre des
antiquaires la fiac des enchères records
paris prouve ces jours ci que le marché
de l'art se porte bien en france pour
que paris puisse faire jeu égal avec
londres et new york
des dispositions ont été intéressantes
ont été prises pour faciliter
l'exportation d'oeuvres d'art et aussi
sur le plan
skull pour baisser notamment de 7 à 2%
les droits d'enregistrement à la charge
de l'acquéreur
george v go nous prouve ce nouveau
dynamisme à paris il y en aura-t-il pour
tout le monde
la fiac offre à la vente 5000 oeuvres
contemporaines
mais d'ici la fin de la semaine plus de
cent cinquante mille visiteurs auront
parcouru les 12 mille mètres carrés du
grand palais où se côtoient 135 galerie
d'art en 20 ans véritable révolution
culturelle les rapports des français
avec l'art ont considérablement évolué
selon l'insee la fréquentation des
musées est passé de 18 à 32 % l'an
dernier plus d'un français sur deux
s'est déplacé pour voir une exposition
quant aux galeries d'art elles n'ont
jamais été si prospère il s'est exportée
en 87 pour près de 10 milliards de
francs de tableaux et d'objets d'art
l'art est un des grands moyenne
communication planétaire et je pense que
le seul langage commun actuellement à
toutes les civilisations et tous les
hommes c'est l'art et c'est pour ça que
vous voyez dans les grandes ventes aux
enchères ou à la fiac des japonais des
américains des allemands
des australiens c'est le seul lieu où au
fond un langage commun les réunit
quand vous jouez en des hadrons deux
millions et demi une commode bull ça
vous paraît normal entre dans cette
commode
on s'approprie une partie de cette
spiritualité de cette énergie de cette
invention de ce moment de civilisation
fantastique tout sauver deux millions et
demi par rapport à ce que vaut un bateau
un avion
je vous donnais un chiffre qui va
relativiser tout ça on parle beaucoup
d'argent von arx mais en gros le chiffre
est peut-être à un média mais en gros
tout le marché des ventes aux enchères
dans une année ça représente minutes de
travail de la bourse de new york à l'eau
new york
oui new york et l'inévitable référence
des professionnels du marché plus
particulièrement en ce qui concerne
l'art contemporain dans la fiac est la
plus grande vitrine
le chiffre d'affaires réalisé ici l'an
dernier est extrêmement important on l'a
estimé à 120 millions de francs cette
année pour le mans 150 millions de
francs ce qui équivaut approximativement
au chiffre d'affaires réalisant une très
grande vente à new york fréquentait les
grandes-ventes nom parle c'est ça
les nouvelles mesures fiscales et les
autorisation d'exporter aidant on peut
espérer un volume d'affaires qui
placerait paris en 1992 en tête du
marché européen
les pronostics de pierre adresse pour le
trc de demain à longchamp le dise le 6
le 3 le 8 le 2 le 5 le 7 et le 13 à
23h40 henri sannier vous présentera
notre dernier journal de ma 6h45 roger
zabel et dans un instant laurent cabrol
pour le temps merci d'avoir suivi ce
journal à demain 20 heures
oh